صناعه السيارات واحده من المجالات التي
تحولت بفعل ذكاء الاصطناعي هناك ايجابيات
فيما يتعلق بالسياره ذاتيه القياده واهمها
عنصر الامان بفضل اجهزه الاستشعار
المتقدمه وخوارزميات التعلم الالي يمكن
للسياره ذاتيه القياده اكتشاف المخاطر
المحتمله والتفاعل بشكل اسرع من السائقين
البشر يمكنها ايضا التواصل مع المركبات
الاخرى وبالتالي توقع الحوادث وتجنبها
مراقبه السائق عنصر امان اخر بعدما تتحقق
خوارزميات الذكاء الاصطناعي من هويه
السائق في السياره تقوم تلقائيا بضبط
المرايا والمقعد وحتى درجه الحراره حتى
انها تراقب حركه العيون وموضع الراس
لاكتشاف النعاس وايقاظ السائق ان تطلب
الامر لكن كما هو الحال بالنسبه لاي تقنيه
جديده هناك مخاطر خطر فشل التكنولوجيا
مثلا اذا فشلت اجهزه الاست شعار في
السياره الذاتيه القياده في اكتشاف احد
المشاه او مركبه اخرى فقد يؤدي ذلك الى
حدوث تصادم مخاوف الخصوصيه سلبيه اخرى
بمعنى ان يتم قرصنه اجهزه الاستشعار
والكاميرات وبالتالي الوصول الى كميات
هائله من البيانات حول تحركات الركاب
وسلوكهم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات